NARRATOR: In Luxor's
Karnak temple,
Colleen is hunting
for clues that
explain Ramses' rise to power.
Ramses was a mighty
warrior and general
who fought in many campaigns
and expanded Egypt's
borders to the east and south.
But the temple walls suggest
that's not the only reason
he became so powerful.
This is a remarkable document.
It's the actual text
to a peace treaty.
NARRATOR: This 3,300-year-old
wall holds 38 lines
of hieroglyphic inscriptions
that lay out in detail
the world's first peace treaty,
an unprecedented promise
of alliance between Ramses
and his mortal enemies,
the Hittites.
It's amazing to see the
text of an actual treaty.
This is the document that
two great powers signed--
Egypt on one hand, and
the Hittites on the other.
NARRATOR: This proves that
Ramses didn't just fight wars,
he ended them, too.
Peace allowed Egypt to
prosper and for Ramses to get
richer and more powerful.
This tells us how neither
the Hittites nor the Egyptians
could attack one another.
And if they were attacked
by a third party,
they would come to
their ally's aid.
NARRATOR: The
Egyptian-Hittite peace treaty,
or the Treaty of
Kadesh, meant Ramses
could finally end his 20-year
war with the Hittites.
Wars are quite costly.
So by having peace, Ramses
is guaranteeing stability
and prosperity in his reign.
NARRATOR: This allowed Ramses
to focus on gathering wealth
and building temples and
monuments that celebrated
his mighty achievements.
COLLEEN DARNELL: A lot of
pharaohs, including Ramses,
used propaganda.
But in the case of
the peace treaty,
these are real terms
with a real foreign king.
So this shows Ramses
wanted everyone to know
that he was a great diplomat.
NARRATOR: Ramses
demonstrated himself
to be the ultimate king.
And his choice of Karnak
to proclaim as such
was no accident.
COLLEEN DARNELL: I think Ramses
is showing the peace treaty
here at Karnak
precisely to contrast
with his military exploits.
He does what he needs
to do to preserve order
on behalf of Egypt's gods.
NARRATOR: Ramses was a
warrior king and a diplomat
who ruled over an extraordinary
period of peace and prosperity.
[music playing]